merci merci cher collègue monsieur le
président sur les mesdames messieurs les
ministres monsieur le premier ministre
la violence de la crise sanitaire que
nous connaissons ne doit en aucun cas
nous écarter de l'impératif économique
et celui de la réindustrialisation de
notre pays la france
entre 2019 2017 et 2021 a maintenu et
créer 140 mille emplois autour d' autour
de autour de plusieurs projets qui sont
de l'attractivité de la france un
élément indispensable aujourd'hui et si
business france reconnaît que la france
est devenue le premier pays en europe en
termes d'attractivité pour les emplois
il est devenu même devant le royaume-uni
situation que nous pouvions pas imaginer
il ya encore quelques années et puis
revenu lundi le jour là dans deux
touches france et tous france a décidé
qu'il y aurait en france une vingtaine
de projets avec 4 milliards
d'investissements pour les années à
venir et même à partir de cette année
ses investissements se traduiront en
france par la création de dix mille cdi
et de 15000 cdi intérimaires qui seront
répartis sur le territoire français
entre les villes grandes villes mais la
moitié pour les villes de moins de vingt
mille habitants c'est quichard collègues
et amis sénateurs devraient réduire la
plupart d'entre nous qui vous battez
pour des territoires plutôt ruraux qui
sont en difficulté mais ces résultats
mes chers collègues ne sont pas dus au
hasard ils sont dus d'une part au
savoir-faire à la connaissance à la
technicité des entreprises françaises
qui se sont adaptés et qu'ils restent
dans bien des domaines et domaine de
luxe je pense à la pharmacie je pense à
l'environnement je pense à la
mécatronique des sujets qui sont
aujourd'hui très important
et ça n'est pas le fruit du hasard ce
n'est pas le fruit du hasard c'est aussi
en regard des mesures qui ont été prises
par le gouvernement concernant
concernant notre activité contre non le
savoir faire concernant les impôts de
production concernant la simplification
pour les entreprises il y à aujourd'hui
en france il ya aujourd'hui en france
14% d'emploi venant d'étrangers qui sont
aidés alors ma question monsieur kone
ministre
ni la question comment le gouvernement
entend t-il prendre des mesures pour
conforter ses acquis et rendre à la
france plus d'attractivité encore je
vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président françois patriat vous avez
tout à fait raison et l'attractivité
mais
je sais que vous manifestez parce qu'en
réalité de ces résultats vous vous
réjouissez
l'attractivité l'attractivité d'un pays
est en effet l'un des indices de sa
santé économique vous avez donné des
indications très précises sur ce que
tous france importé cette année à notre
pays je voudrais élargir le propos
monsieur le sénateur depuis
2010 est entre 2017 et 2020 donc
s'ajouteront les éléments que vous
n'êtes communiqué plus de 5300 projets
ont permis de créer ou de maintenir
140 mille emplois en france grâce aux
investissements internationaux sur notre
pays c'est une excellente chose je pense
que personne ne le contestera et vous
l'avez dit évidemment je ne peux que
vous relayez ça concerne mesdames et
messieurs et sénateurs tout le
territoire j'ai une cartographie que je
tiens à votre disposition la france
entière est innervé par ses projets et
si vous me permettez
d'insister ces projets concours à la
réindustrialisation de notre pays à
laquelle je vous sais aussi très attaché
là aussi là aussi ça oui un peu tard
vous dites monsieur là aussi oui oui les
chiffres vous savez que depuis 1981
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
france a perdu 50 mille emplois
industriels par an 50 me depuis 2010 est
en net nous en avons recréé 30000 certes
on n'est pas encore à la hauteur de ce
qu'on a détruit mais mais le mouvement
est amorcé et je dois vous préciser
d'ailleurs que en 2021 nous avons ouvert
deux fois plus d' usine qu'il n'ya eu de
fermeture et ça aussi c'est totalement
inédit je pourrais évidemment vous dire
illustration de la politique
gouvernementale et de ses conséquences
je pourrais également vous dira tout à
tous que ces chiffres sont en ligne avec
ceux de la croissance économique de
notre pays la plus forte de la zone euro
que ces chiffres sont en ligne avec les
créations d'emplois plus
575000 créations nettes d'emplois aux
trois premiers trimestres de 2010 21 ça
fait des années et des années que ça
n'était pas arrivé que même ces chiffres
sont en ligne je vous le dis avec le
pouvoir d'achat qui a augmenté parce que
créer des emplois c'est la première
mesure en faveur du pouvoir d'achat plus
2,2 pour cent 2021 alors qu'il a reculé
en allemagne
tout ça ce sont des données concrètes
alors qu'allons nous faire monsieur le
président pour poursuivre en ce sens et
conforter ses résultats économiques et
bien tout simplement continuer la
politique économique et sociale que nous
conduisons au service de la france et
les français mais
[Musique]